one of the things I I love about Joe is
Joe Rogan is I went and saw him at uh I
was in Utah with my parents and said
come down come down to the Forum you got
to see this and I'm like you know I was
50 minutes away I think I come down and
I'm I'm just standing in the wings and
watching my friend perform for 14
000 people wow okay I was stuck in
traffic I was going the back way and I
was still stuck in traffic and I'm like
what's this traffic oh they were coming
to see my friend okay so his Fame is as
big as it gets but I got to tell you man
I gotta tell you what I saw which is
probably going to hit soon
that that special is as good as anything
he was doing that got him to the game
wow and that's called hunger that he's
always stayed hungry he's always stayed
uncomfortable